هل أنت في الأسفل
هناك هنا ، تذهب إلى
علامتي تبويب واحدة لأعلى ،
حصلت على أربعة مصابيح جيدة ،
حصلت على مؤشر أخضر أعلى ، احصل على
مقبضين أكثر أمانًا لأسفل ، حسنًا ، يمكنني التحقق من
أن لديك مقابض خادم في الأسفل
هنا ، ويتسون والأسماك
تؤدي حاليًا ما  يُعرف باسم
فحوصات الأصدقاء بشكل أساسي يتحقق
من تكوين بدلة الفضاء الخاصة ببعضهم البعض
والمساعدات المبسطة لإنقاذ إيفا
المقابض
الموجودة على كل حزمة نفاثة يرتدونها
في حالة غير محتملة
تتطلب استخدام تلك الحزم النفاثة للعودة
إلى أمان
محطة فضائية إذا انفصلت ،
أغلق الغطاء الحراري
الذي صندوق إلكترونيات الطيران السريع الذي يبلغ حجمه
61.7 بوصة × 15.3 بوصة ×
11.2 بوصة يزن حوالي 200
رطل وسيتم نقله إلى تروس s3
بواسطة
الطاقم لتثبيته على
الخدمات اللوجستية السريعة  الناقل الأساسي
elc 4. جميع الأعمال الأخرى أه التي
تم التخطيط لها لهذا
السير في الفضاء ذي الطبيعة غير الحرجة ذات
الطبيعة غير ذات الأولوية سيتم
تأجيلها إلى  سير آخر في الفضاء بسبب
أه مقدار طاقة البطارية التي
كان على المشاة الفضائية أن يستهلكها
مع فقد إحدى الخدمتين
وتبريد السرة أثناء الاستعدادات للسير في الفضاء في
وقت سابق من هذا الصباح ،
مما أدى إلى اضطرارهما إلى تبادل
scu واحد
ذهابًا وإيابًا ولكن  أه في
الوقت
الذي لم يكن فيه أحد المشاة في الفضاء
مرتبطًا بهذا
السرة كانوا يحرقون
طاقة البطارية ولذا فنحن نشاهد القدرة الكهربائية
وطاقة البطارية على كل
من البدلتين بحذر شديد ،
يجب أن يكون هناك الكثير  من الوقت
لإكمال الهدف الرئيسي
للسير في
الفضاء هذا والذي سيكون بمثابة التبادل خارج
صندوق إلكترونيات الطيران اللوجيستي هذا
، وبينما تكون هذا هو
الوقت المناسب للقيام بتعديل الترجمة ،
شكرًا لك على
وضع جيد بالنسبة لك ،
إنه أمر بعيد المنال  الجانب الأيسر ولكني أعتقد
أنه
وضع جيد بالنسبة لك لمراقبة مكان وجود
بيجي ويتسون على اليمين باستخدام أداة التهوية
الاحتياطية
كما يطلق عليها "اكسبريس
كار"  مربع إلكترونيات الطيران المجاور لها ،
يمكنك رؤية جاك فيشر آه تقريبًا
خارج مجال الرؤية على الجانب الأيسر من
شاشتك حيث
يتعرف على
الترجمة أو الحركة حول
محطة الفضاء الدولية
فيشر في الدقائق الأولى من
أول سير في الفضاء  من مسيرته المهنية
يشق طريقك إلى مقعد الحافز
لمواجهة واحد فقط تذكير
للحذر من كبلات الاختبار والأوماس السلبي ،
نعم ، ترى أن هذه التعبئة مشتعلة
قليلاً ،
لذا قد تضطر إلى التحفيز
عندما تصل إلى هنا
بخير
الآن جيد جدًا ، لقد حصلت على درابزين آخر
للمحفز
هناك
مع النهاية الخلفية
وأول منظر لكاميرا الخوذة لدينا من
بيجي ويتسون آه ، إن رقم الكاميرا الخوذة
الخاص بها هو 18 الذي تراه في هذا
الرقم الشبح الموجود
في الزاوية اليمنى السفلية
لمقبس الشاشة  سيتم تعيين كاميرا خوذة فيشر على
أنها 20
طوال مسار السير في الفضاء اليوم ،
حيث تحلق محطة الفضاء الدولية على
ارتفاع 252 ميلًا فوق الأرض
وتتحرك من الشمال الغربي إلى الجنوب الشرقي في
أوربي  يميل بمقدار 51.6 درجة على
جانبي خط الاستواء
ويمر فوق جزيرة برمودا ،
حسنًا ، هذا يبدو رائعًا.
إلى القاعدة s3 17. 17. علي
أن ألمس الشمعة الرائعة ، آسف ،
حسنًا ، سأحضرها في طريقي على
ما يرام ، يجب أن أعود على أي حال
وسمكتان من الجيد
أن تتبعهما وتستمر في مراقبة
بيجي كما أنت '  لقد كنت أقوم
بعمل رائع ،
حسنًا ، يجب
أن تأتي الأذرع الآن على
ما يرام ، أعتقد أنك مستعد ولكن يمكنك
المضي قدمًا في ذلك ،
فقط تأكد من أنك تحافظ على المسار
على جانبك الأيسر ،
يا إلهي ، هذا جميل ليس
أكبر فطيرة رائعة ، لم أر قط
صلصة رائعة حول
وعاء الفوندو ، يا رفاق ، وعاء الفوندو الهائل
يتدفق
مع الأنابيب الرائعة ،
يبدو رائعًا ،
حسنًا ،
كان لدينا رهان على الوقت الذي سيظهر فيه أول
رائع نفسه ،
هذه هي المهمة  السيطرة على هيوستن كانت
مجرد مسألة وقت  قبل
أن يعبّر جاك
فيشر عن فكرة رائعة لوصف المنظر من
مسافة 252 ميلًا فوق الأرض ، لكنه فعل ذلك
كما بدأ هو وبيجي ويتسون في
التحرك نحو الميمنة الثلاثة
لمحطة الفضاء
الدولية لإنشاء متجر لاستبدال
هذا الناقل السريع  سوف يقوم إلكترونيات الطيران بوكس
ر بتثبيت أداة تثبيت مح
ولة للقدم في
هاية canadarm2 والتي تراها بش
ل بارز في مجال الرؤية في هذه ال
ورة ، وسوف يقوم بزرع خل
صته في مكان العمل وسيتم قيادته حول موقع العمل لمساعدة whitson في
استبدال صندوق إلكترونيات الطيران هذا
بواسطة مشغل الذراع الروبوتية توماس
بيسكيه الذي سيعمل
من محطة العمل الروبوتية
لمختبر القدر
لمحطة الفضاء الدولية التي
تعبر الحبل للحظة فقط ،
لذا سنستخدم هذه الصورة الكبيرة بالطبع.
أحزمة معدات قابلة للتعديل في الجزء السفلي من الحقيبة
لمحاولة تخزينها
وتكون زاوية ذروة المنفذ أو
الزاوية اليمنى
العلوية عميقة  g للذهاب إلى هذا الدرابزين
3002 ، دعامة زينيت ،
حسنًا ، أنا على الدرابزين الآن ،
ها هي محطة عمل القائمة الخاصة بي في
القسم ،
وسأبقي هذه الحقيبة أسفل ddc
لذا فهي بعيدة عن طريقنا إنها رائعة  معك
حسنًا ، هذا يبدو رائعًا
الآن ، حدد خمسة وسبعة وستة صفر
منظر بانورامي لموقع العمل لـ
Whitson and Fisher أثناء قيامهم بإعداد متجر
في الجانب الأيمن من ثلاثة تروس
لمحطة الفضاء الدولية
بجوار الصورة الكبيرة التي سنذهب إليها
ابدأ في إعداد ssrms ،
وبمجرد أن يتم تأمين هذه الحقيبة ، يمكنك
الترجمة مرة أخرى إلى عربة أرز الميمنة
لاسترداد apfr من
الرقم 4.
هو أن الرقم الصحيح صفر صفر اثنان
يؤكد أن دعامة زينيت
جيدة وهذا واحد والمزلاج أحتاج إلى ذلك
قم بفكها على طول الطريق ،
اجعلها تعمل مع الآخر ،
نعم ، يجب فك كل شيء قابل للتعديل
على طول الطريق ،
حسنًا هنا ،
دعنا نذهب لنرى ما إذا كان بإمكاني تدوير هذا
الطرف ،
أحتاج إلى الدخول وإلغاء قفل crt الخاص بي ،
هل حصلت عليه ، نعم حسنًا ، هذا هو
الخوذة  مراجعة الكاميرا من جاك فيشر
أثناء وصوله إلى موقع عمله
على s3 Trust بمحطة الفضاء الدولية
، سيبدأ العمل لإعداد
مسند القدم المحمول المفصلي
في نهاية
الذراع الآلية canadarm2 لحظة أو اثنتين
من
الآن ستكون هذه محطة العمل
الخاصة به أه وهو يتجول في موقع العمل أه
مثل مصلح الهاتف في نهاية
منتقي الكرز
أه يعمل بالتنسيق مع بيجي ويتسون لاستبدال صندوق
إلكترونيات الطيران السريع
على ما يسمى elc 4 the
شركة النقل اللوجيستي السريع
، منصة قطع الغيار في تلك المنطقة
من الجمالون
لمحطة الفضاء الدولية ،
تريد مني أن أقوم بتثبيتها أو فقط
انتظر هناك بيجي
أم فقط انتظر حتى تضطر إلى
التباهي بهذا
الانتظار ، يمكنني الحصول عليه شكرًا ،
أريد هذا مرة أخرى  زاوية أيضًا بما أنني
هنا ،
سيكون ذلك جيدًا ، إنه
ركن nader الأيمن الذي
سيتحرك حول الدرابزين ميل علامة 5640.
مهلا ،
يمكنك المضي قدمًا
والخروج وسأحكم عليهم داو  إذا كنت تريد
حسنًا ،
نعم ، هذا ليس بعيدًا بما يكفي
، سيكون هذا قريبًا
بما يكفي ،
سأمنحك الاستقرار ، حسنًا ، حسنًا ،
أعتقد أنني سأقوم بضم
النادر أول
30 دقيقة إلى السير في الفضاء اليوم فقط
لتلخيص
الطاقم بدأ في السير في الفضاء رسميًا في الساعة
صباحًا بالتوقيت المركزي متأخرًا بساعة تقريبًا عن
الجدول الزمني
أه قبل الساعة 4 صباحًا بالتوقيت المركزي حدث
تسرب صغير
عند الاتصال بين إحدى
الخدمتين وسرة التبريد
التي توفر طاقة تبريد الأكسجين
والاتصالات
للمشاة في الفضاء أثناء
استعدادهم للمشي قبل الفضاء
في قسم قفل المعدات
بغرفة معادلة الضغط في الوقت
الذي تم فيه توصيل السرة ببدلة جاك
فيشر وعلى الرغم من أن
بدلة الصياد كانت في حالة مثالية ، فلا توجد
مشاكل هناك
و  كان الطاقم على ما يرام أيضًا ،
وكان لا بد من معالجة هذا التسرب
في تلك المرحلة ، وكان على ويتسون والصيد
تبديل استخدام الخدمة الأخرى وتبريد
المبادلة السرية للخلف وللحصول على  لتوفير
التبريد
والطاقة الكهربائية لبدلاتهم ، ولكن أثناء
القيام بذلك ،
أحرق كل من أفراد الطاقم قدرًا معينًا
من طاقة البطارية في هذه العملية
حتى
تمكنوا من التحرك داخل
قسم قفل الطاقم في
المهمة وإزالة الضغط عن قفل الطاقم
تقريبًا إلى الفراغ
ولكن الآن بعد أن أصبحوا خارج الطاقم
بالطبع ، تم توجيههم في وقت سابق
إلى رحلة سير في الفضاء
مختصرة لمدة أربع ساعات
فقط حيث سيتعاملون مع مهمة واحدة فقط ، وهو
الهدف الأعلى للسير في الفضاء هذا وهو
استبدال
إلكترونيات الطيران السريعة  box أو expeca
كما هو مشار إليه في s3 truss
لمحطة الفضاء الدولية ،
وهذا أمر مؤكد ، وستكون هذه الإعدادات الخاصة بك
لـ ssrms ، وسأنتقل
إلى أعلى ستة
نسخ fox ، وسأقوم
بتحريك هذا قليلاً إلى
أبعد من ذلك.  سأحمل الحقيبة
بشكل أفضل قليلاً ،
هذا هو الناتو ،
حسنًا ، أعتقد أن حقيبتنا آمنة الآن
، نسخة جيدة ، وللتأكد من أننا
في نفس الصفحة لدينا ، لدينا
ثلاثة ريش قابلة للتعديل لأسفل.  قبعة
صحيحة ،
هذا صحيح ، هذا يبدو رائعًا
بحيث تكون الحقيبة آمنة ، وبعد ذلك
يمكنك إسقاط الخطاف الأخضر
على الدرابزين s3 3011.
أنت تعمل على apfr ، أعتقد أنك
ربما تكون قد صدمت زر wvs الخاص بك ،
لذا إذا كان بإمكانك تدوير ذلك من
أجل
نحن ولدينا نسخة wvs الخلفية الخاصة بك
peggy بعد ذلك ، سنطلب منك
استرداد المغرفة المربعة
من الإصدار الاحتياطي x pekka h1 وهذا هو
أقصى حد في نهاية الصمامات
ويمكنك
تخزين ذلك على mws على
نسخة apfr ، عمل رائع ونراكم  ضع نقل
ذلك إلى brt الخاص بك
نسخة peggy بمجرد أن تكون هذه المغرفة على ما
يرام انسخ مجاذيفتين للخارج آه سمكتين
يمكنك العودة إلى um ، ثم
ترجم إلى نهاية s1 إلى
الذراع ، وعندما تكون في طريقك ،
يرجى الضغط على عربة الأرز  لقد حصلت على
دواسة تحرير الفرامل مرتين
، بمجرد أن يتم تخزين تلك المغرفة المربعة
على mws الخاصة بك ، فسوف
تستعيد كرة مكدس الكرات
مع
المقعد المدمج وخياطة ذلك خلف شريط mwst الخاص بك ،
يبدو أن
هذا الشيء
هو على الدواسة
نسخ الوتد ونسخ سمكتين من  k أنت
واحد آخر
، آه وسمكتان فقط صورة كبيرة بالنسبة لك ،
ما زلنا نرفع ذراعك ، لذا قد
نحتاج منك
للتوقف مؤقتًا هنا للحظة ،
حسنًا ، خلفك مباشرة ،
نسخ عمل رائع ، آه ، كلاكما ،
بيجي هو عنوانك  نادر فقط
بضع تحذيرات وتنبيهات اه
لاقتناص أهداف تركيبات الكلاّب التي تستهدف الزعانف والأعمدة ، ثم في elc 4 نريد تجنب
حركات جسم البطارية القوية وكما قد تتذكر
في حمام
السباحة سنبتعد عن
جانب المبرد وشاهد قدميك
مقابل
مجموعة كاميرات cp3
، حسنًا ، ثم على x-pick نفسها ،
شاهد الأسطح المطلية
ولن نترجم على أي
مغارف مربعة نفهم
سجنًا ننتظره ، هل تعتقد أنني
هل يمكن أن
تبدأ هاتين الخطوتين الأوليين وتلقي
الدفيئة الخاصة بي للحصول على uh
marker 5820 ، ليس لدينا تلك الحقيبة
هناك ، لا
نذهب إلى
هناك ونقف لمدة دقيقة
أجنبيًا وبيغي ، أراك في pekka السابق
يمكنك تثبيت مغرفة مربعة من
ميغاواط  s على h3 المتوقع الفاشل وهذا سيشير
إلى
المنفذ وسمكتان كنتما تتصل بهما بشأن
إسقاط الخطاف الأخضر
إذا كنت لا تمانع ، فسنقوم فقط بهذا
الأمان للمبادلة الأخرى معًا
كواحد كمجموعة واحدة بمجرد أن نحصل على
تم تثبيت apfr
الخاص بك جيدًا وأه بيجي لدينا متسع من الوقت ننتظر
حتى يتم تدوير الذراع ، لذا فقط آه
لأخذ وقتك
حسنًا ، لقد فاتني الريشة من Squarespace و Peggy
مغرفة وهي غير مقفلة ،
هذه نسخة جيدة صحيحة بعد ذلك ،
سنعمل على
uh ball stack mutt الذي سنقوم
بتثبيته
على الدرابزين elc 4 8803
لذلك سنقوم بتحريك النهاية المجانية
للتراجع
على ذلك  كومة الكرة المغفلية سنقوم
بتوصيل ذلك بالدرابزين 8803 لبدء
مظهر [الموسيقى] الرائع بعد ذلك ، سنقوم
بتوصيل مؤثر النهاية المغفل بهذا
Uh 8803
سيكون لديك  الفكين يثقبان
الخلف على الجانب الضيق من
الدرابزين ونريد اه  المستجيب النهائي الذي هو
الأبعد عن
طوق المكدس الكروي الذي يحتوي على تلك النهاية المجانية
للممثل ،
نعم ، يجب أن أعود
وأطلق صوتي ، لقد كنت بعيدًا جدًا ،
فأنت أراهن أننا نتحدث الآن عن
سمكتين لذا قف  في غضون دقيقة واحدة فقط
اقتربنا قليلاً محليًا الآن ،
كيف تشعر أنك
بخير ،
نحن مستعدون لواجهة برمجة التطبيقات في المتجر إذا كنت
تعمل على الفرامل
على الجانب الآخر ،
حسنًا ، دعنا نفعل
ذلك يبدو جميلًا من قبل  بالطريقة التي أتمنى
أن أتمكن من خلالها من أخذ الاعتمادات لذلك ولكن
أه ليس أنا ، لا أعتقد أن هذا كان ملكك ،
حسنًا بيجي ، نرى أنه لديك
فكي أمامي رأينا أنك تقفله ،
لذلك انظر إلى توجيه الكرة
إلى الأمام
ثم الانحناء عند السمت ، نريده
يمينًا قليلاً بحيث يمسح
مظروف العمل المتوقع
ومن ثم يمكنك فتح فكي هذا
المستجيب النهائي بحيث يكون جاهزًا
لاستلام مقبض المغرفة المربعة
، ثم أخيرًا ستجعلك بيجي
تحرك الحقيقي  نهاية مندوب
من تأثير نهاية mutt  أو إلى
نقطة الربط المتوقعة
التي يبدو عليها الأمر بشكل صحيح ،
فهذه هيوستن هي مركز التحكم في المهمة بعد 46
دقيقة من السير في الفضاء اليوم الذي
بدأ في الساعة 808 صباحًا
بالتوقيت المركزي ، هذا المنظر من
كاميرا خوذة بيجي ويتسون في
السير في الفضاء التاسع من مسيرتها المهنية حيث تقوم بإرفاق
أداة ملحقة بـ
الدرابزين الخاص بـ s3 truss
لمحطة الفضاء الدولية حيث سيتم تخزين
صندوق إلكترونيات الطيران السريع الحالي
الموجود على s3 Trust بمجرد
إزالته مؤقتًا
لصالح مكون بديل
تم نقله على المركبة المدارية
atk cygnus لإعادة الإمداد الشهر الماضي
سأعود
وأفتح هذا بيجي الرائع
بفضل كاميرا خوذة جاك فيشر 46
أو نحو ذلك بعد دقائق
من أول سير في الفضاء في مسيرته ،
سيكون هذا مرة أخرى سيرًا مختصرًا في الفضاء لمدة أربع ساعات
مع مهمة واحدة فقط في الجدول وهي أن
تكون البديل
من صندوق إلكترونيات الطيران السريع
هذا والموجود في واحدة من أربع
منصات مستودع لقطع الغيار على طول الجمالون
لإحصائيات الفضاء الدولية  أيون يحتوي على
وحدات استبدال مدارية
قطع غيار مهمة ،
ويستخدم صندوق إلكترونيات الطيران هذا لتوجيه
القياس عن بعد
إلى التجارب داخل محطة الفضاء الدولية
، وحقيبة قفل الطاقم من علامة الميل 5760 على
ما يرام
وسمكتان لمدة 20 ثانية
لتسليمهما ، سألتقطك على الجانب الآخر
بالنسبة لمبادلة حبل الأمان ،
يبدو جيدًا ،
مدير رحلة الأصدقاء ، جريج ويتني ، هنا في
التحكم في المهمة ، أه
يتطلع إلى الساعة بعناية شديدة
بسبب أه
قدرة طاقة البطارية المنخفضة أه
لكل من
بيجي ويتسون وجاك فيشر بسبب
الفقد المبكر لإحدى الخدمتين
و  تبريد السرة في غرفة معادلة الضغط
أثناء الاستعدادات للسير في الفضاء ،
لقد قمت للتو بسحب فريقه ، لقد ألقينا نظرة على
المكان الذي وصلنا إليه على الجدول الزمني ، قبل وقت
قصير من الجدول الزمني
من حيث الوقت المنقضي على مراحل
منذ بدء السير في الفضاء
حوالي 49 دقيقة  في الماضي ونحن
نمضي قدمًا
في استبدال صندوق إلكترونيات الطيران هذا
على s3
truss jack ، تعمل حاليًا على
تثبيت جهاز محمول  ضبط القدم
في نهاية الذراع الروبوتية canadarm2
التي سيتم دفعها بواسطة Tomah pesquet من
وكالة الفضاء الأوروبية
من محطة عمل محطة عمل روبوتية
لمختبر القدر
في الموقع المداري
، حسنًا
يا صديقي ، أنا مستعد لنفعل ذلك ، لقد حصلت عليه  اقفل
البكرة باللون الأخضر ،
وبالعودة إلى اللون الأخضر ،
تحقق من أن خطاف أقفال الخطاف الأخضر
مغلق ، حرك خطافك الأصفر إلى
بكرة اليد ss rms
أو نقطة ربط السكة اليدوية مع الشيكات القياسية
التي يتم إغلاقها بشكل أفضل كما هو الحال في الأسود ،
يتم ترك نسخة
يمكنك إسقاطها  خطافك الأخضر على الدرابزين s1
3208 وأنا أستخدم 3207.
هذا ليس
جيدًا ، يقوم جاك فيشر بإنشاء متجر
ليربط نفسه
بالذراع الروبوتية للمحطة الفضائية الموضوعة
في موقع العمل s3
Trust حيث سيبدأ هو وبيغي ويتسن قريبًا
العمل من أجل
استبدل صندوق إلكترونيات الطيران السريع
للأشخاص الذين يتابعوننا على وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
هذا الصباح ، وقد تم
طرح عدد من الأسئلة على
facebook twitter و instagram
لدينا بعض الوقت للإجابة على اثنين
تسأل تلك جنيفر على فيسبوك
لماذا عليك أن تمر
بعملية الضغط وإزالة
الضغط
قبل وبعد عمليات السير في الفضاء التي
تشير إلى غرفة
معادلة الضغط ،
فإن الإجابة موجودة في الفضاء هناك
فراغ
على الرغم من أن الطاقم محصور
بذاته.  بدلات الفضاء
التي تعمل كمركبة فضائية مصغرة
لأنفسهم
ولكن عليك أن تخفض الضغط لأسفل
لتتطابق مع حقيقة أنها فراغ
بالخارج قبل أن تتمكن من فتح الفتحة
ثم إعادة ضغط غرفة معادلة الضغط
بحيث تكون في
جو عادي بمقصورة 14.7 رطل / بوصة مربعة
أمامك  يمكنك إزالة بدلة الفضاء الخاصة بك
كاثرين على فيسبوك وتطلب من القفازات
التي ترتديها أثناء السير في الفضاء أن تبدو
خرقاء بشكل فظيع كما ترون في
بعض اللقطات التي رأيتها
من تقييمات كاميرا الخوذة من
سائرين في الفضاء ،
هل من الصعب فهم الأشياء
معهم وصفها السير في الفضاء بأنفسهم
كمحاولة القيام
بعمل معقد باستخدام
أدوات صغيرة ومسامير وأدوات قبضة كهربائية ،
يبدو الأمر أشبه بارتداء زوج من
الملاكمة  القفازات لكنهم مدربون جيدًا
لعدة سنوات على هذه المهام
ويمارسون الرياضة باستمرار للحفاظ على
قدرة عضلية فائقة الذكاء في
أيديهم
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى] أجنبية
[  تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
هذه
أجنبية
[موسيقى]
عني